Yeah.
It's very biking.
Yes.
Acts just acts is always land the right way.
That's what always Fripp freaks me out.
I feel like it would,
my handle would bounce off the wall and it would just fly somewhere weird in a
movie.
The guy grabs the knife by the blade like this and it always lands with the
blade in the body.
Imagine if someone threw a knife at you and the handle hit like this.
You're like,
oh bitch,
you just can't.
You have a knife.
This knife and I'm going to hold on this after death grip and slide it into your
rib cash.
You mentioned this yesterday,
but someone duals that were a lot of duals.
I heard a stat.
I didn't,
I never knew about it that Andrew Jackson was in something like a hundred duels.
What?
He only killed one person.
I thought he killed a lot of you usually get shot in the arm or like you know
like a musket ball would go like your legs are the one where he killed the guy.
He actually,
it was a,
I forget the actual guy's name,
but he was known as being a really good doula.
He killed a lots of p like 26 people or something like that.
So we challenged this guy and he thought the only way to win would be to let him
take the first shot.
So he let him take the first shot,
got hit in the chest,
was bleeding,
covered the hole and then shot the guy and he died.
Whoa.
He shot him in the head.
He city fell immediately and then died like a couple hours later I think.
I don't know if he was the president at the time,
but the doctor said like,
I don't know how you stood and took that shot and he said,
if he shot me in the brain,
I was going to stand and take that shot to kill this guy.
I don't know if you said like motherfucker or whatever,
but like Andrew Jackson was crazy.
This guy.
Yeah,
he's a crazy dude where his,
where is where the statue of him is and I'm in Jackson Square in New Orleans.
There's that church that's behind it and that this is why New Orleans is
supposedly the most haunted city is because they'd had the most duals.
Because once a Andrew Jackson contacted John Laffite and was like,
I need an army.
And John the feet was basically a gangster,
which is basically someone that can get you anything.
Like that's what a connected guy does.
And so he got him freed slaves,
native Americans,
creoles Cajuns and just,
you know,
angry men and they repelled the British.
But then they stayed and they just lived in the bars and they were dual happy
because their egos were so big.
And I've looked for these and I can't find him.
What they had was dueling cards where if you had one,
it would say Joe Rogan have your face.
You know,
probably that image and it would say,
you know,
dueling card and someone bumped into you and you were like,
you just give them your card and be like,
see you in the morning motherfucker.
And that means we're,
we're shooting it out.
Whoa,
you would dual over nothing.
And the guy I went in the scope,
this ghost tour and the guy taught me,
they told me this story and he said,
imagine the amount of guys who are hung over woke up like,
oh fuck,
what did I do?
I've got a dual now.
And you'd go behind that cemetery.
That's where they'd have their dual.
And imagine laying there with a bullet or a piece of round led and your liver
and going like,
I'm dead over this shit.
It's like I stepped on my foot.
They keep cards like dueler carts.
No,
this is just like a picture of one.
They also said that a lot,
a lot of times the uh,
the dual wouldn't actually happen.
Like they might not actually shoot.
It was more of a test of will of like,
yeah.
Will you go through with it?
Yeah,
it was all honoring.
They'd have to bring a second guy to make to like verify that the dual actually
went down and said one was a pussy or whatever.
Serious.
He's like the judge of the event.
He's laying odds.
It's like,
he's like,
ah,
do certain states were duals or legal?
I think there's still legal in Arizona or the used to be because there was a cop
who shot someone in a duel like years back.
Really?
Yeah.
It was a,
it was a weird thing.
Like a cop was off duty and he shot someone in a duel.
Oh Man.
I want to say this is more than 10 years ago,
so maybe they changed the law,
but I remember reading that going what?
You can do dual dashboard saying Texas.
Well,
yeah,
this only,
what's that fist fucking dude?
What is that?
Well.